今天要跟大家聊一個，我覺得很有趣的創業故事。一對夫妻，在他們家鄉找不到一種他們很想要的服務，結果他們自己動手做了，然後六個月內，營業額就破百萬美元。
嗯，百萬美元，六個月，聽起來很厲害。但等等，創業故事很多，這種「找不到就自己做」的，成功案例其實也不少。它到底特別在哪裡？
特別在於，他們做的不是什麼高科技，也不是什麼多麼創新的商業模式。他們只是開了一間自助式優格冰淇淋店，叫做 16 Handles。
自助式優格冰淇淋？這東西台灣很多啊，感覺一點都不稀奇。為什麼在美國的 Forest Acres 這個地方，會變成一個百萬美元的生意？這點我有點不明白。
其實，這就是讓我最詫異的地方。我們常常覺得，要創業就是要搞個什麼沒人做過的點子，或者要解決什麼人類的重大問題。但 Ken 和 Sarah Barlow 這對夫妻，只是因為他們的女兒想「自己做冰淇淋」，發現家裡附近沒有這樣的店。
所以他們就覺得這是個商機？這也太…直覺了吧。他們沒有做什麼市場調查，或者分析競爭者嗎？
他們當然有做研究。Sarah 提到，他們夫妻倆都是 Forest Acres 的美食愛好者，很常光顧當地的商店。他們意識到這個「市場空缺」不只對他們女兒重要，對其他像他們一樣的家庭也一樣。他們看重的是，這不僅是個需求，更是一種「帶來快樂」和「連結社區」的機會。
嗯，聽起來還是很…感性。不過，能夠在六個月內達到一百萬美元的銷售額，光憑「感性」應該不夠吧？他們具體做了什麼？
關鍵在於「在地」和「社群」。Sarah 說他們成長的很大一部分，就是選對了地點，以及從開業第一天就積極投入社區。他們選了一個交通流量大、人口密集的購物中心。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。選對地點，人潮就是錢潮，這算是最基本的經營法則。但「積極投入社區」怎麼說？是發傳單？辦活動？
他們的做法很具體。自從開店以來，他們為當地超過 70 個非營利組織舉辦了募款活動，還積極支持當地的運動隊伍、學校和舞蹈團體。Ken 甚至強調，這些社區合作和在地活動不只是「錦上添花」，而是對營收和建立忠實顧客群有實質影響。
等等，辦了 70 場募款活動，這工作量不小吧。而且這樣真的划算嗎？這些投入會不會侵蝕掉利潤？
這就是與一般想法不同之處了。他們沒有把這些看成單純的支出，而是建立社群連結、創造重複消費的策略。他們透過這些活動，讓更多人認識他們的店，並且產生情感連結。畢竟，誰不喜歡支持一個會回饋社區的在地店家呢？
這點倒是有意思。所以，他們是把行銷預算轉化成社群經營，然後再透過社群反饋到營收。這樣聽起來，成本可能沒有我們想像的那麼高，而且效果可能比傳統廣告更好。
對，而且他們選擇加盟 16 Handles，意味著他們有品牌的基礎和營運的支援，不用從零開始摸索。這也降低了創業的風險和門檻。
如果我是創業者或主管，這裡面學到的，就是不要小看「身邊的不方便」或「市場的小空缺」。而且，在地連結和社群經營，就算不是高科技產業，也能創造驚人的營收。
沒錯。那如果是一般的上班族，能從這個故事學到什麼？畢竟我們沒辦法直接開一間店。
我想，我們可以把這種「觀察身邊的需求」的習慣帶到工作或生活。比如說，在公司裡，有沒有哪項流程特別不順手？哪個工具大家都抱怨？這可能就是一個可以優化或提出新專案的機會。
嗯，或者是，下班後，你覺得家裡附近的哪種服務特別缺乏？或許那不一定是創業點子，但也能提醒我們，多留意生活中的細節，可能是發現新機會的起點。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候，巨大的商機就藏在我們看似微不足道的日常體驗裡。